hey there folks Chris waters here at San
Diego comic-con on the gamespot stage in
joining me now brian hong director of
marketing for project cars brian welcome
thank you excited to have you here
comic-con treating you guys well yeah
we're having a great time we got our
booth on the floor showing off all our
games including project car including
project cars which we've got in action
right now and this is you know it it's
one of these a garden-variety beautiful
racing game that like makes you really
glad you bought in the next-gen system
right absolutely absolutely yeah we're
really excited about the game project
cars is the community assisted racing
simulator by the studio's slightly mad
or racing game fans they'll remember
that those are the fellas that were
small person need for speed shift when
we got a lot of fans of that on gamespot
actually and i can you said community
assisted right so what is that I mean I
feel like the challenge for a racing
game is to carve carve out a niche and
it sounds like community assisted it's
your thing what is it yes this is the
first triple a racing game that was
actually crowdsource so through the
world of mass development the stevie has
been able to get donations and members
to join this community and they've been
getting access to play the bills in a
couple of weeks and buy tons of their
feedback on what they want in a racing
game do they want that turn to be a
little wider is that uh they want to be
unforgiving you know they they it's been
great because they've been providing a
lot of reference imagery a lot of
feedback on the handling oh cool so yeah
the studio has said they'd like to say
that this is a racing game for racers my
erasers yes so that's a question I mean
you know you're getting feedback on the
handling of these cars and I feel like
the kind of people you know not everyone
who's giving you feedback on it has been
behind the wheel one of these on a
racetrack but so but there are these
enthusiast communities that you can tap
into and the knowledge base there is
just tremendous it is and because
they've been able to give that
feedback it's actually allowed the
community an unprecedented level of
involvement you know in the game design
he they run polls to see you know what
tracks do you want what cars do you want
so they're really it's not just kind of
lip service like hey thanks for your
money we're going to go make the game
they've been asking hey what tracks do
you guys want to see what cars do you
want in the game how do you want the
game to be you know set up and put
together so and I've I imagine that can
also get a bit challenging for you guys
because you know yeah I want to see
every license track across the planet I
want to see some space tracks on and I
like I mean you guys got to narrow it
down a little bit there are sort of
developer design decisions you have to
do to sort of pare it down so what's
been the would have been sort of the
boundaries you guys have been sort of
trying to channel all this feedback into
into well i think that the developer
definitely wants to try and please as
many of the fans as they can but they do
understand the end of the day this isn't
the only racing game that's come out
meaning to this point so i think they're
trying to find that good balance between
you know offering out cars that people
want to see versus having cars in there
that are unique and you know maybe not
seen before so well which I gotta ask
now what kind of cars are unique in not
seen before I mean are we talking like
concept cars or well you know yeah
they've got a lot of different cars not
just the most modern ones but they've
got a lot of the classics in there as
well I know that most recently they
talked about their their partnership
with Nissan so the GTR which is the
favorite car of you know car fan boys
everywhere okay the 2014 nismo is going
to be in the game no so that should be
pretty exciting sure that's probably a
car that is it's all that I'm not like
super power that ya know if you get into
one of those things that the
acceleration space ripping it's awesome
so yeah well tell tell me about you know
so I am NOT like a you know a super
knowledgeable when it comes to car
racing obviously what's what's this game
for me what you got well the the tracks
and the cars we've talked about I think
when you think about the level
handling the game features one thing
that differentiates this this game from
once before it is when you get started
in the game you're going to have access
to race all the cars and the different
disciplines right out of the gate okay
that's one thing that I think the
community is kind of said hey why do I
have to race forever to unlock
everything run through this entire class
of cars I don't really care to drive
just to drive the one I really want i
want to open up the cabinets I want to
see peanut butter jelly I'm gonna get it
off you got some rich cabinets delicious
yes oh so doctor I guess talk a little
bit about the structure of the game you
know that is there sort of do you teach
art a career do you like you sort of
work within different discard
disciplines and car types yeah there's
ago there's the GT racing there's open
wheel there's even kart racing in season
mode you can get right in create your
own race car driver and as you go into
the different disciplines and you have
success in there basically you'll gain
the accolades points and your your
reputation points and as you get in when
you want to do online racing with
they've tested it struck to stress
tested up to I think 30 30 plus at the
same time they tested it but right now
they are talking about having about 16
to 20 multiplayer okay so this is great
because if you start your own lobby and
it's private you could race with your
friends if you want to if you just want
to go out and compete against other
racers of your same ilk the network
driver series in there will actually
match you with people have about the
same level of driving experience as you
as well and is that so that's tied to
that reputation you were talking about
and in your own in-game successes and
how much time you put into it right all
right and so in terms of online modes I
mean are we talking just kind of like
one-off races like a little so racing
series or any kind of grander plans
along like a year-long Formula One
racing competition I think it's going to
allow you to have the flexibility to do
the one-off races as well as get it too
much longer
series in the seasons so I know that
they're still working out a lot of the
details on the setup of the game if they
get in with the community and keep
getting their feedback but that's and
that's and that's that's leading up to
release but if you're I feel like if
you're a community-driven game you
release the game that your community
gets bigger because now people can
actually get the game in their hands you
can let them know through the game like
hey we're community driven game are you
guys gonna be continuing that kind of
support and that kind of you know
tweaking and adding new content based on
community desires after release right
yeah because the way that the game
development has gone I mean they've been
constantly getting feedback and running
those tweaks yeah I think the intent is
fully to continue on getting that
feedback all the way through in a lot of
ways this has been something of an
experiment in terms of game development
I mean I think fans have never had this
much access and input in the developer
is slightly mad is trying to make sure
that everyone's voices are listened to
well that does sound slightly mad but I
the game looks like it's shaping up
pretty well and I guess is it possible
so folks if they watch this demo and
they're thinking like like to community
I'd like to community contributes to
this this slightly mad endeavor is there
a way that they can sort of get involved
well they actually once they started the
funding I believe they had over 80,000
folks ultimately sign up to join the
community mhm they had six tiers that
you could actually buy into you know
starting from junior all the way to
senior member and i gave you different
levels of access and different levels of
interaction with the developer but i
think right now when you think of just
that alone that that's kind of unique
but another piece that we haven't talked
about yet is virtual reality that's
sorry that's the reality yeah future so
one of the things that they want this
game to be compatible with is the oculus
rift and the project Morpheus sure
headsets so they'll be giving up more
details on you know how that actually
works but we do know right now that
been doing a lot of testing on it
they've been posting videos on YouTube
showing the you know the physics with
your with your head you know inside the
helmet didn't kind of seeing the 360
perspective so kid that is something
we're really excited about to show once
it you know kind of gets off the ground
that's neat yeah and it's i mean that's
a lot of developers are sort of telling
us that they're experimenting with it
they're checking it out but like it that
you know and i think that you know in
the next year it's really looming that
we're gonna get to see so many of these
games yeah put into the oculus rift into
the the Sony Morpheus and see how it
turns out is very exciting but speaking
of peripherals you guys are also
offering a support for a range of
driving peripherals yes the wheels and
pedals and should write stuff like that
yeah I mean there's been a lot of
licensing partnerships that the studio
has made I know that with thrustmaster
that's kind of a pretty pretty favored
you know peripheral system absolutely
yes that's very popular yeah we got it I
got some questions coming in on the game
spot comments of sort of project cars
stuff we've had up on the site and
people are curious about about that
range of cars about you know are they is
it licensed cars and tracks or are you
guys created any of your own like yeah
journal tracks or original cars or
anything like that so depending on the
racing discipline most of the tracks are
authentic tracks that you'll see you
know I think some of the tracks are are
created by the developer but that might
be more for like card series type okay
but a lot of the the racing here that
you see whether it be able bonds or the
GTO tracks that's going to be some
authentic fact and those Kart series
racing they've got like loop de loops
and jumps and items and stuff like that
right yeah yeah yeah let's see let's see
all right so project cars it's coming
out this year yes it'll be coming out
November of this year the PlayStation 4
the xbox one the steam platform and then
in 2015 first-ever wii u version so no
kidding that's going to be pretty crazy
to be like hot tap the wii u thane to
honk the horn cuz honking horns is like
an integral part of car racing under
professional levels that's been my
feedback
I wanted a horn and this is a good yeah
hey we're community we're giving you
community feedback my voice counts my
voice sounds all right so uh project
cars coming out in November and again
for folks who are interested in sort of
keeping an eye on it and may be
contributing are their forums our
website Dickens yeah there's plenty of
forms they can go to the wmd portal and
find the cars project cars page in there
or they can go to project cars game.com
as well alright Brian thank you very
much for coming by thank you for on
project cars